عشرات القتلى بتحطم طائره في نقال وفيديو
يرصد الكارثه مصالحه محتمله بين الاميرين
هاريو ويليام قبل تتويج والدهما امريكي
دفع دولارين وفاز بثاني اضخم جائزه بتاريخ
اليانصيب هذه الاخبار وغيرها منقولها لكم
من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
في حادثه الماساويه هي الاعنف منذ 30 عاما
في نيبال لقيا العشرات مصرعهم بعد تحطم
طائره على متنها 72 شخصا بالقرب من مطار
في وسط البلد تقارير تحدثت عن مقتل جميع
من كانوا علمتنا الطائره وان البحث جار عن
اربعه مفقودين مشيره الى ان الحادثه وقع
اثناء هبوط الطائره ثم شبت فيها النيران
كما اظهرت لقطات فيديو انتشرت على
السوشيال ميديا طائره تحلق على ارتفاع
المنخفض فوق منطقه سكنيه قبل ان تبدا
بالدوران بسرعه حول نفسها وتسقط
منذ ان تخلت البلاد فجاه عن سياستها
المشدده صفر كوفيد في مطلع ديسمبر الماضي
توفي عشرات الالاف في الصين نتيجه تداعيات
الاصابه بفايروس كورونا رئيس قسم الشؤون
الطبيه في ان اي تي سي
قال ان الصين سجلت نحو 60 الف حاله وفاه
مرتبطه بقوه في الفتره من الثامن من
ديسمبر الى الثاني عشر من يناير من بينها
نحو خمسه الاف
وخمسمائه وفاه نجمات عن فشل التنفسي سببته
عدوى فيروس كورونا اضافه الى نحو
54.000 في حاله وفاه كانت لاشخاص اصيبوا
بالوباء هو كذلك الامراض الاساسيه كسرطان
والقلب والاوعيه الدمويه
مازالت ازمه الامير هاري تتصدر عناوين صحف
البريطانيه والجديد هذه المره هو حديث بعض
وسائل الاعلام عن مصالحه المحتمله بين
هاري والعائله الملكيه قبل تتويج الملك
تشارلز الثالث في مايو المقبل مصدر مقرب
من الملك وعلى ايضا قال لصحيفه صنداي
تايمز ان اجتماعا سيعقد بينهم في الفتره
المقبله قبل حفل تتويج الملك موضحا ان
الامر سيتطلب مرونه من جميع الاطراف لكنه
ممكن والامور قابله للاصلاح وشدد على ان
كلا الجانبين يحتاج الى التلاقي والاعتراف
[موسيقى]
كشفت وكاله الفضاء ناسا عن خطه جديده
لبناء خليفه لتاليسكوب جيمس واب الفضائي
ستكون مهمته الرئيسه البحث عن كواكب صالحه
للسكن الوكاله واوضحت في احدث اجتماع
للجمعيه الفلكيه الامريكيه ان خطه تطوير
التلسكوب القادم تقوم على هدف ان يجعل
مناسبا للبحث عن علامات الحياه على
الكواكب الخارجيه الصالحه للسكن في الفضاء
الخارجي فيما تحدث موقع سبيس المتخصص في
اخبار الفضاء عن ان المرصد الجديد سيدعم
جهاز تطوير او جهاز تصويرا فائق القوه
لتمكين العلماء من دراسه الاجسام الفضائيه
وسلوكياتها على اختلافها
وفي خبرنا الاخير اعلن منظمون يانصيب
الامريكي ميجا مليانز ان مواطنا ربح جائزه
قيمتها مليار وثلث و 350 مليون دولار في
ثاني اكبر مبلغ يتم ربحه باليانصيب في
التاريخ شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه اشارت
الى ان التذكره الفائزه بيعه بولايه مين
وثمنها دولاران كما تطابقت ارقامها مع
جميع الارقام السته الفائزه فيما لم يتم
تحديد مالك تذكره بعد ولديه خياران اما
الدفع الفوري وعندها تنخفض الجائزه الى
723 مليون دولار بسبب الضرائب واما تقسيم
المبلغ على 30 عاما على ان يدفع على شكل
تعويضات سنوي